I don't even just love the biological
argument because I sort of think it
partakes of the Same Soul denying
scientism that got us in this mess in
the first place you know if the answer
to what is a woman is 2x chromosomes in
a womb I think well you know I think
there's more to it than that man maybe
sugar spice and everything nice a woman
is much more than her body but a woman
is at the very least her body and it's
not like this is a brand new question
that cropped up we do have thousands and
thousands of years of very sophisticated
thinking on what constitutes a man what
constitutes a woman but the moment you
try to engage in that conversation the
transgenderists run away because there
there is no way to defend it the big
divide I see here is not between the men
and women and the trans and the whatever
the opposite of trans is it's between
people who view human Humanity as being
made up of intellect and will got an
intellect so I can perceive the truth
and I've got a will so I can act on it
and the people on the left who say
forget that intellect stuff it's all
about the will